okay today I'm going to talk to you
about mitosis mitosis is a process which
happens in living things to create new
cells now this could be really important
when we think about growth because if an
organism is growing we need to make new
cells and also it can be really
important in repair as well for example
if I was to accidentally cut myself I'd
need to replace those cells and produce
new cells also certain things such as
bacteria reproduce by this process the
basic idea of mitosis is you start off
with one cell and then it splits and it
gives you two identical daughter cells
um what we're going to do is we are
going to discuss exactly how this
happens the different stages and what is
going on during mitosis so the very
first stage in mitosis is called
interphase so during this phase
here's my cell membrane and here is my
nucleus now Dominique was quite big here
we have all of the DNA that is really
kind of spread out in long strings
remember the DNA is where all of the
genetic information is stored for an
organism so what we wanted to do is
we're wanting to make an exact copy of
this cell here now what happens to begin
with you in interphase is the DNA is
copied the DNA is copied so what you end
up with is all the DNA in these things
called chromosomes which look like this
now a chromosome is just lots of DNA all
coiled up in this particular structure
so this side here this arm here is
identical to this arm here I've done
them in different colors to help us in
just a second so that is interphase
where we have the long strands
the DNA duplicates it copies itself so
now we have one copy here and one copy
here held in a chromosome so next up we
have prophase now in prophase the
nuclear membrane so this is the little
membrane around the nucleus starts to
break down and these chromosomes get
shorter and fatter okay so here's my
chromosome now in a human you'd have 23
pairs of these chromosomes okay but I'm
just going to draw a few just so it's
nice and quick okay so now this nucleus
is broken down these chromosomes are
just free within the cytoplasm of this
cell okay now the next stage is called
metaphase now during metaphase the
chromosomes line up across the middle of
the cell that's how I remember it
metaphase starts at the NAMM and so does
a word middle so you can see here's one
chromosome here so you can see they've
lined up across the middle now what's
going to happen in a minute is half of
these chromosomes going to be pulled
this way and half been pulled this way
because what we want to do is we're
trying to make two new cells which are
identical to each other and this happens
during the phase called anaphase so
during anaphase we have these things
form called cell fibers okay now cell
fibers what they do is they actually
pull the chromosomes apart this is how I
remember anaphase because a is for
anaphase and a is for apart so we have
cell fibers at each kind of pole of the
cell so each end of the cell
pulling them apart so this one that
shown in red is going to go this way
remember this copy and this identical
copy of the same chromosome it's going
to be pulled the other way so what we
end up with is half of the genetic
information going this way and half
going this way what we next have is a
phase called telophase now during
telophase we've started so let's say
here's what it starts to look like now
all of these chromosomes that have been
pulled this way the blue ones are now
this side and all of these ones
shown in red are this side so we have
half of the genetic information here and
the exact copies of each of these here
we also have started to form two new
nuclear membranes remember a nuclear
membrane is just this layer containing
all of the nuclear material this
membrane here that's how I remember
telophase because I think of two new
nuclear membranes have been formed one
here and one here now the final stage
that we need to think about is a stage
called cytokinesis now all that this is
is where the new cell membrane starts to
actually form just here and eventually
these two cells are going to pinch off
from each other and we're going to be
there no longer going to be attached so
in cytokinesis we now have one of the
cells here and one of the cells here so
those here under cells yes so they are
no longer attached they have now come
apart from each other and they should be
and I'm an exact genetic copy
identical to our parent cell
so the beginning this one here is our
parent cell because this one's the one
we started off with and these ones here
are our daughter cells because these the
ones we've ended up with so we have
interphase prophase metaphase anaphase
telophase and cytokinesis and this is
how this is what the chromosomes the DNA
is doing at each stage thank you